our show is the most kind of awkward
embarrassing and kind of real show on TV
that deals with that color of comedy I
think we're the best in that in that
genre which we inherited from the from
the brilliant English show but what's so
interesting to me is how much young
people like that kind of humor
they love older people they don't like
it they're like I can't watch it it's
too awkward it's too painful if people
are too gross it's they're weird they're
mean and it's awkward I can't stand it
young kids I mean down to 9 10 11 12
year olds they eat it up they love the
office they have it memorized they love
that kind of awkward humor I don't know
what it is but it seems that Ricky
Gervais swooz able to just capitalize
almost on a generational shift with an
understanding that so much of the comedy
is not in the setup setup punchline
there's very few jokes on our show it
really is behavior characters behaving
and the reactions to that behavior you
know do Idol do something stupid but the
laugh is on Pam watching it or Jim
seeing it and then turning to the camera
because that's I think how young people
I make up that's how young people feel
today you know they're seeing all of
this absurdity and it's like if they
could young people would just be like
and just look at the camera
so it's let's say a comedy of
awkwardness and more comedy of of
reactivity
I really like the stuff that's very
absurd and very real at the same time I
think anton chekhov is the greatest
comedy writer of all time I think he
would make a great addition to the
office staff you look through Chekov
plays there's a lot of awkward pauses in
there his mixture of pathos absurdity
truthfulness and whimsy is just mixed
together perfectly